deutschland liegt im jahr 1918
militärisch am boden man kann sich
natürlich fragen warum erst 1918 in
deutschland ist seit 1914 seitdem der
krieg begonnen hat
ein unterlegener gegner die mittelmächte
verfügen über weniger menschen und sie
sind auch wirtschaftlich schwächer das
ist der grund warum die oberste
heeresleitung die für deutschland den
krieg plan versucht 1914 eine schnelle
entscheidung im westen herbeizuführen
was nicht gelingt im jahr 1918 versucht
deutschland ist noch einmal denn der
krieg gegen russland wurde gewonnen es
stehen 45 zusätzlichen division zur
verfügung und als das nicht gelingt als
dieser plan missglückt sind letztlich
die probleme die deutschland schon mit
sich herumträgt wie hunger wie fehlende
versorgungsgüter es gibt eine
seeblockade seit 1914 und auch die immer
schlechter werdende moral der truppen 2
millionen deutsche soldaten sind zu
diesem zeitpunkt schon gefallen lässt
sich verstärkende faktoren dazu dass
generalstabchefs ludendorff der wie ein
diktator über deutschland zu diesem
zeitpunkt bereits herrscht sich an den
kaiser wendet sich an die regierung
wendet und sagt es macht keinen sinn
mehr weiter krieg zu führen
ich schlage vor dass wir einen
waffenstillstand mit den amerikanern
versuchen abzuschließen der
kardinalfehler den die oberste
heeresleitung im frühjahr 1918 begangen
hat war letzten endes nicht entschieden
genug gegen die täter vorzugehen es gab
dieses momentum den sieg über russland
durch den zusätzliche division frei
wurden und das war letzten endes auch
der einzige vorteil den deutschland im
jahr 1918 noch geltend machen konnten
die amerikaner waren zu dem zeitpunkt
bereits in den krieg eingetreten es war
nur noch eine frage der zeit bis die
vereinigten staaten mit hunderttausenden
zusätzlichen soldaten und einer schier
unerschöpflichen quelle von ressourcen
waffen und material die deutschen zurück
drängen würden eben in diesem zeitpunkt
hätte es nur eine möglichkeit gegeben
noch einen sieg fliegen wie in judendorf
anstrebte wirklich realisieren zu können
das wäre ein massiver konzentrierter
stoß gewesen
entweder um die briten ins meer zu
drängen oder eben um paris zu nehmen und
durch eine dieser beiden möglichkeiten
ein sieg frieden herauszuholen und den
gegner zu zeigen dass es quasi unmöglich
ist deutschland unter annehmbaren kosten
noch in die knie zu zwingen das ist
nicht geschehen das hat eine reihe von
gründen letzten endes lag es daran dass
die oberste heeresleitung nach vier
jahren des stellungs krieges nicht in
der lage dazu war entschlossene noch auf
bewegungs krieg umzustellen es gab zwar
einzelne ansätze dazu es gab stoß
truppen es gab taktiken es gab auch
waffen die letzten endlich schon sich
günstig auswirken darauf dass die
deutschen noch fortschritte machten es
gab nicht diesen einen stoß die oberste
heeresleitung verzettelte sich von
anfang an in operation wo man versuchte
über verschiedene teile voranzukommen
und dann kam halt auch noch hinzu dass
für den moment des front durchbruchs und
was danach kann man keine weiteren
konzepte mehr hatte letzten endes wohnen
reservekräfte an widerstandsnestern zum
einsatz gebracht und nicht dorthin
gebracht wo man eh schon einen
durchbruch erzielt hat womit man den
gegner hätte umfassen können
und es gab noch eine reihe weiterer
gründe dafür wie das die artillerie und
die infanterie nicht zusammen spielten
kurzum am schluss war der vorstoß nicht
entschieden genug und im juli 1918 war
das spiel entschieden die amerikaner
waren da und nahm das heft zusammen mit
den franzosen und briten in die hand und
ließen es sich dann auch bis zum ende
des krieges nicht mehr aus der hand
nehmen